hi there steve kaufman here
it's a lovely
sunset that i'm looking out at here it's
been a great day or at least the second
half of the day was warm at long last
we're getting summer here in vancouver
i had a great workout this evening when
i came home from work and i went for a
swim in the ocean for the first time
this summer
a little chilly but our water here never
gets very warm
so i feel good
i want to talk a little bit about korean
uh i
in my previous video i talked a little
bit about uh the different books that i
bought
on learning korean that i i spent um you
know six or eight months about four
years ago on korean
uh listening to
content that i got from
the colloquial series the teach yourself
series a book out of ubc here other
things that i could find
and eventually i just stopped because
the content available was just simply
too boring
and then we had russian link and i moved
over to russian
but now we have korean at link so i'm
back at my korean and i want to talk a
bit more about my experience
by the way in my previous video when i
showed this great stack of books that i
had spent money on
and
criticized some of the books for their
overly sort of technical linguistic
description of sounds and things of that
nature which i never can quite relate to
of course that inevitably triggered a
criticism
on my youtube channel from someone who
probably did study linguistics and says
that i shouldn't call myself a linguist
if i can't understand those terms and
of course in english the word linguist
means polyglot that's the first
definition you find normally in most
dictionaries
so i don't apologize for calling myself
a linguist even though i never studied
linguistics
and even though i'm not very interested
in the subject
i'm also not very interested in all of
those linguistic terms i don't i don't
find them useful for language learning
they may have other uses
uh also this gentleman then accused me
of you know blatantly pushing link and
you know it's pretty easy to see what
i'm up to and stuff well yeah it is easy
to see because it's obvious
uh i enjoy doing these videos and
interacting with people but i wouldn't
do them if it weren't for the fact that
i'm hoping to attract people to link i
mean that's why i do them but that
doesn't mean that i don't believe in
link why do i ever get involved i've
been in the lumber business all my life
i don't really need it
i believe in it i believe there's a
better way of learning languages and so
i have committed an awful lot of time
to this project and we have invested uh
obviously money and uh and i believe in
it
and and it's my passion what's wrong
with that what's wrong with talking
about things that are interesting uh uh
of interest to me uh there's no hidden
agenda here it's pretty clear some
people may say that i mentioned link too
often whatever i'll do what i want
someone else can make videos and talk
about what they want to talk about
now getting back to korean
i praised the colloquial learning korean
and i think the main reason is because
it was smaller than the other books
but i have now found having gone back to
it that yeah i can read through the
chapters 1 to 20 and i kind of half
start to remember what i had learned
before
but i couldn't listen to the cds anymore
because they're full of english
and i can't stand it uh you know first
of all they explain to you in english
what you're about to hear which
really annoys me
then they give you vocabulary with
english
explanations and then they ask you
questions plea and please answer in
korean and i find all of this stuff very
very annoying
so i was very happy that
hyunwu sun or i guess korean style sun
hyun wu
who has a website called talk to me in
korean
agreed to share
these dialogues in our link library the
dialogues are called talk to me in
korean they are tremendous intermediate
learning material tremendous the sound
quality is excellent
it consists of either hyun wu or someone
else usually there's a male and a female
it could be two females
and they talk about light subjects it
could be um
you know it could be bookstores whatever
i had bookstores lazy people
um
hmm
stress dealing with stress uh exercise
all these subjects talking about
everything and nothing really but in a
very pleasant way
natural
unscripted just two people having a
conversation but they managed to repeat
words over and over again so it's very
good for the learner
uh it's great listening even if i don't
understand it all i don't mind listening
again and again
and then of course i read it on link and
i look up the words that i don't
understand
and one of the things that i find quite
interesting with korean is that
with so many words you don't find a
satisfactory explanation in the
dictionary
part of it is because there are a lot of
words perhaps words that come from
chinese
that can have seven or eight meanings so
you don't know which one applies to this
particular context
or for some reason sometimes the
dictionaries just turn up ridiculous
uh
meaningless
definitions so
but you know what i don't mind this and
i think this is a good exercise they
should they should i think they should
do this in classes they should give
people dictionaries full of meaningless
uh
you know or 15 different definitions
and make them realize that
that
you know the language you're not going
to nail it down and even if they were
what looked to be the real meaning it
you're still not going to nail it down
so the fact that things are a little
fuzzier in korean
it just makes me want to listen more
often i'm more i'm keen to hear more and
more
of of content in korean because i know
it's eventually all going to fall into
place because the koreans make sense
when they talk to each other so
therefore eventually korean's going to
make sense to me
but
as i said on my blog post it's kind of
like a you know a beautiful woman she's
not gonna
make you aware of of of everything and
let you see everything right away you've
got to put in the time you got to put in
the effort and gradually you'll get to
know
the language
uh so i'm really enjoying korean from
that point of view um
also because we now have our our uh
again plugging link we have our app our
new app on ipod i'm able to do a a lot
of my reading
listening
i can review my saved words highlight
words in the text
on my
on my ipod app i can review my
flashcards i can even review my links of
the day that get emailed to me they also
line up in this app so i mean i can do a
lot of stuff i i had the meeting today i
was this gentleman was actually i met
with a canadian minister of government
to try to talk to him about
link and of course politicians are
always busy so i was uh you know left to
wait there but i was just as happy as
could be going through my
my uh korean on my little ipod shuffle
so that also has made the korean fun but
i am enjoying it and i think i'll
probably spend a month or so on the sort
of lighter intermediate stuff here talk
to me in korean i don't know how many
episodes there are i will find out
and then i'll move into heavier content
where
to some extent i'll have an advantage
because there will be a lot more uh
words that are based on chinese
characters and so i will have a lot of
that vocabulary from my chinese
so yeah i'm enjoying it the biggest
problem i'm gonna have with korean is i
set myself a challenge to see
um you know how much i can do between
now and december and i want to try to
have a conversation with someone in
december
but i'm going to portugal in october so
i also don't want to neglect my
portuguese i'm actually going to be
giving some uh conferences to to
language teachers in portugal before
that i have a conference in germany so i
do at some point have to refresh my
german
then because it's my 65th birthday my
wife and i are gonna spend
three weeks in sardinia
uh
my older boy and family are gonna come
over from england because they have
holidays at that time at least for one
week and then we're going to spend
another two weeks and then i want to
maybe drive through italy back up to
france or fly home but
so italia is going to be there and in
all of that i'm going to have to
maintain my korean studies
so that
in december i can actually carry on a
conversation in korea we will see how it
goes meanwhile thank you very much to uh
for the wonderful content you and your
team have created and talked to me in
korean thank you very much bye for now